merci vraiment
il faut en laisser pour benoît
[Applaudissements]
ici
merci à tous merci vraiment
merci
les merci et bravo à vous surtout vous
avez toujours été là l'exercice de la
vie quelques combats au dénouement son
solution mais avec des motifs valide
m'ont appris à regarder la personne
humaine sous l'angle du ciel dans le
bleu d'orage lui est le plus favorable
c'est de rené char et c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous faisons de la
politique
nous faisons de la politique parce que
nous avons le souci de la personne
humaine de sa dignité de son intégrité
de sa relation aux autres de son
émancipation de son épanouissement de sa
participation au destin commun de son
rapport à l'environnement de sa
compréhension du monde
nous faisons la politique parce que nous
savons que dans les sociétés plurielles
les opinions divergent que des volontés
peuvent se confronter et que des
intérêts s'affrontent pour permettre la
vie sociale aussi bien au quotidien que
dans l'espace public
il existe deux modes de régulation soit
la force avec tous les arbitraires que
cela suppose
soit le droit c'est à dire des règles
qui s'imposent à tous nous faisons de la
politique et nous la faisons à gauche
parce que nous osons porter un regard
critique sur l'ordre social pas pour
déclarer la guerre à qui que ce soit
mais pour affirmer et afficher notre
parti pris pour des rapports de justice
plutôt que des rapports de force
nous choisissons de protéger les plus
vulnérables et la classe moyenne plutôt
que de les livrer à la dureté du marché
aux casseurs de la fonction publique
nous refusons de considérer que la
pauvreté la précarité sont un mal
nécessaire ou une variable d'ajustement
entre l'abondance et l'opulence les
faisons de la politique nous la faisons
à gauche et nous voulons la faire à
hauteur de la puissance publique
nous n'allons pas gaspiller l'expérience
acquise
nous ne voyageons pas léger pendant
cette campagne vous parlerons de ce que
nous avons fait pour vous avec vous des
ministres des députés des sénateurs vos
élus locaux vous diront ce qu'ils ont
relayé ce qu'ils ont soutenu ce qu'ils
ont amendé ce qu'ils ont enrichi nous
vous dirons nous mêmes le sens de
l'action accomplie le sens aussi de nos
refus mais surtout nous vous parlerons
de ces routes nouvelles que nous vous
proposons d'emprunter ensemble et nous
commencerons pas vous dire combien nous
sommes fort combien nous sommes riches
de ce que nous sommes avec nos
tempéraments tous ici et bien au delà
mais surtout avec nos expériences
multiples à travers nos engagements
syndicaux associatifs politiques à
travers nos expériences professionnelles
ces morceaux de vie sociale qui nous
permet de nous rencontrer de nous
connaître d'agir ensemble
après avoir beaucoup discuté c'est comme
ça que nous sommes
mais cette ingéniosité que vous déployez
au quotidien pour faire face aux
problèmes matériels aux fins de mois
difficiles à cette précarité qui
s'infiltre et parfois s'installe cette
créativité dans l'adversité
renforcés par certains en particulier
que nous avons de mêler toutes nos
diversités individuel culturelles
territoriales
cette ingéniosité et cette créativité
sont un capital extraordinaire pour
affronter les épreuves collectives et
pour maîtriser notre futur vous verrez
nous allons faire le compte de nos
talents le tour de nos habiletés
l'inventaire de nos capacités et vous
verrez un nous allons nous éblouir nous
mêmes
les tons qui viennent sera encore
difficile un peu difficile mais qu'une
chose soit difficile nous est une raison
de plus de nous y tenir
c'est de rainer maria rilke la gauche
toujours accéder aux responsabilités
partant rude
lorsque la croissance est en berne que
les finances publiques sont exempts le
chômage tenace que les perspectives
s'estompe au point de s'éclipser que de
nouveaux dangers surgissent que l'europe
se dévoie que le monde vacille que la
confiance déserte
la gauche est toujours arrivé au pouvoir
dans ces moments rude parce que les
intérêts des incertitudes ainsi que le
désespoir se mêle aux convictions pour
confier à la bouche la conduite des
affaires publiques et la maîtrise de
notre destin commun de centre de la
gauche est toujours arrivé au pouvoir au
moment où les impatiences sont maximales
où les espoirs sont intenses où
l'urgence est extrême
c'est pour ça que les déceptions
commence à piaffer dès le premier jour
mais nous saurons faire face nous sommes
bien décidés à faire face nous sommes
décidés à faire face parce que nous
avons conscience des dangers qui nous
menacent des défis qui sont devant nous
et ces défis sont multiples les
bouleversements économiques les nouveaux
rapports sociaux
la très très grande mobilité des
ressources financières
la raréfaction des ressources naturelles
la fragilité des écosystèmes les
nouvelles circulations humaine et puis
ces espaces il faudra dégager amplifié
pour permettre que la culture recommence
à irriguer nos pensées
et nos modes de vie
et bien sûr bien sûr il y à ces périls
de déflagrations qui viennent dans nos
lieux familiers semer la mort la haine
la peur cette violence aveugle et
massive vise le socle même de notre
société démocratique et essaie de faire
croire que nos libertés nos valeurs
seraient des faiblesses mais en
résistant à la tentation de riposter à
l'instinct nous avons démontré non
seulement notre maturité
notre courage mais nous avons consolidé
nos valeurs nous avons surtout fait que
nos forces restent des forces
c'est pour ça que ce monde qui change a
plus que jamais besoin de la gauche il a
plus que jamais besoin d'égalité
d'égalité pour les territoires délaissés
dans les quartiers périphériques
les communes rurales d'égalité entre les
citoyens tous les citoyens l'égalité
d'accès aux savoirs aux soins au droit
aux emplois aux responsabilités nous
sommes en capacité d'assurer cette
égalité mais nous allons commencer par
être vertueux en assurant l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes
non plaît pas
nous les femmes dit elle en regardant
benoît nous les femmes nous sommes la
moitié du ciel et même un peu plus nous
entendons nous entendons être la moitié
de tous à vos moitié la moitié de tous
et surtout
surtout être au moins la moitié
partout où se prennent des décisions le
monde qui vient devra s'habituer à la
présence partout la présence forte de
nos filles de vos fils
avec toi veut de moi
avec toi benoît nous partons à la
reconquête des coeurs et des esprits
nous sommes bien armés nous avons des
atouts notre histoire notre vision du
monde
nos valeurs notre projet ce projet que
tu portes avec tant de force et
d'énergie
nous allons redevenir une gauche de
combat plutôt qu'une grosse de printemps
nous avons le pouvoir
nous avons de quoi
parce que l'héritage des héritages et
dense et foisonnant
nous voulons nous mettre à la hauteur de
ceux qui nous ont précédés au service de
ce même idéal d'égalité
ils ont cru la fraternité possible et
l'ont mise en oeuvre concrètement par
des politiques d'émancipation et de
solidarité ils ont proclamé ils ont
démontré que nos libertés sont
précieuses mais qu'elles sont fragiles
et qu'elles peuvent dépérir
si nous ne sommes pas nous mêmes les
vigiles nous sommes dans le prolongement
de cette longue histoire qui a fini par
confondre les combat pour l'émancipation
individuelle le progrès collectifs la
cohésion sociale avec le combat pour la
république et nous revendiquons cette
filiation
nous sommes bien résolu à mettre en
cause toutes les formes de domination
d'oppression d'exclusion ici et ailleurs
nous pensons qu aucune différence ne
peut servir de prétexte aux inégalités
nous combattons les discriminations et
les exclusions
nous pensons que les destinées
individuelles
ce fort et s'épanouissent dans le destin
collectif
nous sommes dépositaires des avancées
démocratiques des conquêtes sociales des
progrès civique qui nous viennent de la
révolution de la deuxième république du
front populaire du conseil national de
la résistance des législatures
mitterrand de la législature jospin et
même de la législature qui s'achève et
nous portons au tout ce qui est fidèle à
nos idéaux à nos combats à nos
engagements
on a justice sociale la liberté l
égalité
nous sommes
nous sommes fils et fils des communes à
des trésors d une armoire de la
république
nous continuons à thuré enseignements
des batailles anticoloniale des luttes
syndicales des mobilisations écologistes
nous savons ce que l'éducation populaire
peut t'apporter pour consolider le lien
social
nous aimons la vigueur de la laïcité
ce principe de concorde qui nous permet
de transcender nos différences nos
singularités nos appartenances de façon
à nous réaliser 1 nous apprend clients
en égalité au sein de la république
voilà d'où nous venons et nous en sommes
fiers mais quelques soient les
enseignements dont est chargé le passé
le passé n'est pas notre présent et il
ne nous exonère pas d effort pour
inventer notre avenir
et si nous regardons ce que nous ça
capable de faire vous verrez que nous
sommes capables de rendre cet avenir
lumineux où allons nous oui benoît tu as
commencé de continuera à ces les routes
que nous allons emprunter ensemble
d'abord refusé ici et ailleurs que la
dignité de femmes d'enfants d'hommes
soit daigné et porter toutes ces causes
nous disons que l'économie n'est pas
obligé d'être brutal et que l'économie
collaborative
fait la démonstration d'un possible
partage l'économie circulaire montre
qu'il est possible de réduire les
gaspillages la vieille économie a encore
du souffle d'ailleurs et il nous faut la
considérer l'accompagner à la mesure de
la longueur des vies qui lui ont été
consacrés et qui lui sont encore
consacré nous pensons que les services
publics contribuent à la citoyenneté et
que les solidarités sont des joyaux de
civilité et le caractère même des
civilisations
[Applaudissements]
nous pensons que le repli sur soi le
rejet des autres sont des réactions
vénéneuse que les égoïsmes sont une
impasse qui ne profite qu'au trafic en
influence
nous voulons veiller au bien être bien
vivre donc tous les territoires dans les
villes dans les quartiers délaissés dans
les communes rurales et les communes
abandonné et si nous considérons les
défis qui sont devant nous nous
affirmant qu'il n'y a pas de rivalité
entre les pauvretés les détresses tu ne
peut y avoir de compétition entre les
solidarité et l'hospitalité
alors nous allons regarder
nous allons regarder ce que nous avons
déjà été capable de faire et nous allons
constater qu ayant passé tant de
péripéties affronter tant de drames et
de tragédies nous serons capables de
traverser les temps qui sont les nôtres
même s'ils sont parfois funeste et
surtout nous refusons la guerre de tous
contre tous et bon pour surmonter offs
nous allons écouter paul eluard nous
vivons dans l'oubli de nos métamorphose
sommes nous prêts ou loin de notre
conscience
où sont nos bornes nos racines notre but
les rendez-vous donné par la face aux
profils par la souffrance à la santé
dans la lumière à la forêt par la mine à
la fleur par la montagne à la vallée par
le soleil par la perle au soleil nous
sommes corps à corps nous sommes père à
terme nous naissons de partout nous
sommes sans limite
christiane taubira pour qui on peut
montrer encore plus d'enthousiasmé ce
midi à la mutualité
ce discours de christiane taubira
l'ancienne garde des sceaux